you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Ryan I'm having uh
some back issues not happy I thought it
was a kidney infection I was actually
hoping it was a kidney infection because
I don't want more back problems
it's not no blood in the urine uh just a
lot of muscle pain so bear with me bear
with me I'm hanging in there I'm sorry
to hear it it happens it happens I I
mean uh I was doing really well for a
while so
but I'm hoping in a couple weeks this
will subside or or sooner I hope you're
enjoying your week enough about my back
pain and old person stuff
uh got a great show today and
um if you didn't know the live podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum
live we're going live I love your
support we're doing it at the Regent
Theater on October
11th at 7 pm and my guest is Zach Levi
it's live I'm trying to get one of those
little things that shoot out t-shirts
and stuff I thought that's what you were
gesturing to do yeah
uh and um it's gonna be great
uh Zach's a lot of fun he's funny maybe
I'll get him to sing or something but
get your tickets now there's VIP tickets
there's only a certain amount of VIP
tickets so you don't want to mess with
that you want to get in on that uh but
you can go to my Instagram you know when
Zach's I believe you can go anywhere uh
Instagram my link tree into my bio and
you can get tickets and come support the
podcast some come support see live
theater here that's going to be fun it
really is going to be fun I'm excited
about it a lot of cons coming up
so it's also on the link Tree Rhode
Island DC Salt Lake City
um the inside of you online store I've
got great new zip up inside of you
sweatshirts which there's not a ton left
so get them and new tumblers autograph
leximus scripts and other stuff
um and the band sunspin we have our
vinyls at now we have new hats with new
logos we've got new tumblers sunspin.com
I'm on the Cameo all that stuff and a
lot of good stuff going on man
um you know John heater and I have the
reality show coming out so we're you
know that will come out next year and
it's a it's about it's it's two guys
who love horror who are going around the
world to see what really is scary and uh
it's gonna be fun it's gonna be fun I
get scared pretty easily when it comes
to creepy stuff but you love it I love
it it's like an adrenaline rush man it's
like a ride at Magic Mountain a roller
coaster I get that feeling like oh I'm
scared I'm scared but it doesn't happen
often because there are mostly crappy
horror movies out there
um quick shout out to the things that I
support
foodonfoot.com.org foodonfoot.org for
helping the homeless situation my friend
Rob Danson works with that organization
and they're wonderful they really help
people and uh Ronald McDonald House of
Los Angeles
um
and arm Animal Rescue Mission
if you want to help out there and most
importantly uh well not that least
importantly is the patreon to support
the podcast so if you want to support
the podcast patreon.com inside of you
and I'll send you a message you're
really helping the show without you we
couldn't do this show so if you want the
show to stick around please do it Jamie
Kennedy is someone I've known for years
and we did a little movie together
um it didn't do that well but we had a
blast doing it and that's the most
important thing which we forget
if you have fun doing something and it
doesn't turn out the way you want just
look at it as a great experience and
Jamie was surprisingly
um open about life career health
uh it it surprised me in a good way that
I didn't know how open he'd be and he
really impressed me and it was a
fascinating uh interview and I'm glad he
came on the podcast So Jamie thank you
he texted me a couple weeks ago I was
like is this gonna air we had a lot in
the can so it's finally airing and we're
very excited
and without further Ado let's get inside
of Jamie Kennedy it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode in any we air
before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
how how long have I known you bro I'm
gonna say
25 years I think we met you want to know
where we met
does it embarrass me no but you might be
scared I shouldn't is it a spa I want to
say
1999 or 98
Playboy Mansion
Playboy Mansion and it was you Tom
Arnold and no and Tara Reid you know why
and you were and go ahead and I just
remember we were getting on the bus to
go back because they take you in a bus
up to the mansion yeah because you can't
drive your cars up there unless you're
really big time and it was like some one
of the weird parties it was our my first
party there there's only two good
parties which is mid-summers and
Halloween yeah and this was like a
sponsored like Geico or something it was
like a Sunday afternoon swim
and it was like we were done at four and
you're like
all right like where's the after party
like you were you were a gung-ho for
four more parties I mean how old was I
you were like 20 and I was like 22 and I
was like let's go
I don't know if we found wow I remember
because it was right we on the shuttle a
lot of good relationships are made on
that shuttle there were it was always
the fun just kind of letting go and
laughing and yeah yeah oh yeah 20 wait
so I was with Terry we had just done
urban legend and it hadn't come out yet
yep
and you because you are like you're the
scream guy I got a movie coming up urban
legend I'm an urban legend guy so you're
the guy who is the original and I'm like
the Third Rate guy
I would never call you Third Rate
Michael well you know did it sort of not
upset you but I'm sure like you're
watching you got all the success and
screaming all that stuff and all these
spin-offs start happening like [__]
rip-offs rip-offs where you like that or
you're like you didn't care I mean I was
so young so I was like you know it
happens but I mean you definitely are
like that's kind of like our movie or
that's kind of like our movie but you
know at that time everything was coming
out yeah Jeepers Creepers I Know What
You Did you know so many different yeah
that was uh but we all got to work in
them
yeah so I've known you so you're saying
I've known you for 25 years we met then
and then we really didn't get to know
each other until the WB days and then we
started doing the upfronts and hanging
out then we went to the I remember we
went to the Golden Globes together we
had a good time we've met Morgan Freeman
yes hello Jamie Kennedy
that's good dude I like to experiment
how often do you do that I never do it
no really I never do more I don't think
I'd do a good mortgage that was good the
only way I get into is like I remember
the first day I met Andy yeah damn dude
is that good that's good you never do
that on the show never do it on the show
dude
I don't think it's because it's not one
of my things but I know you do a lot of
Impressions I do but I can't I mean I
was I'm not that's how you kind of like
you were that guy in the beginning when
you were growing up and you were always
doing impressions are they sort of dated
now is what you think I well no dude I
think a good impressionist I think a
good impressionist is the Holy Grail to
me I think it's so hard
to do Impressions so if you do them well
it shows such a range of talent and I
think wow yeah I but I don't know if
people realize I don't know if they
value them as much as I do because to me
impressions are everything but I didn't
know that I didn't know I didn't know I
thought they were just like oh I have a
good year and I kind of mimic voice I
didn't think I was it was a talent it's
a super Talent dude off the cuff you
just did Morgan Freeman I'm gonna say
that was 90 similar rate really do it
again say you've been next
you been next
is that really good pretty good dude uh
you know I think my my good ones are
like Dangerfield and stuff like that
let's hear it you gotta close your eyes
hey I'll tell you what we got Jamie
Kennedy here Jamie I my wife told me to
take out the trash I said hey you cooked
it you take it out all right oh how are
you bro two for two so I'm talented very
talented I always no it said that about
you you're an on you're an undervalued
Talent really yeah you know what I kind
of feel that way I mean in a way like
I'm like hey I could do a lot of stuff
and I don't get the opportunities to do
the stuff that I think I could do bro
you're a great conversationalist you can
do many Impressions you can do
characters you're never fake on film
thanks I mean sometimes I could be fake
I know you're you're always in the
moment really even when we're doing
kicking at old school that's right we
had it was a fun movie but you are
always
in the moment like it was real yeah even
though it was a comedy and that's what
makes it funnier as you know play comedy
real and I remember you would always
throw [__] at me you'd be like all those
Rosie Rosie try this try do this dude no
uh do it like oh yeah that's funny it's
funny yeah it was it was like did you
like that or no I loved it I love when
people throw [__] at me I I don't I
don't like I don't like when they say
hey instead of saying this line when she
says that say this line and then when
she says that's it I I can't sometimes I
can't put my mind together to wrap it
around to connect I'm thinking too much
I like to kind of have it for a minute
but that's like throw words out or throw
like little change that sentence say
this I'm okay can you do that are you
good like that yeah I like the Improv
improvises one thing but when they're
throwing things at you to say oh
oh like the exact words I get when you
do like a procedural and you leave an an
out and they're like and the body was
there's nothing worse than that it's
like come on dude this is all this
Exposition no one gives a [__] yeah I
know and you did you've done that I've
done a lot of that well uh whisper Ghost
Whisperer we whisper did you have a lot
of that expositional sort of like
I I'm trying to tell this yeah in the
simplest way we we were the number one
show on Friday yep and I was a guy that
sometimes well wait a minute the ghost
was at 33rd and Anderson but if it went
two blocks down and then the Ghost came
back to 32nd Street it was all this
stuff and I would mess the street up and
I'm like do people really care if it's
Anderson or Atherton you know what I
mean and they'd be like well the street
name is Anderson I'm like look
here show my Exposition cut to the ghost
cut the J-Lo's face
number one on Friday that's all you need
don't worry you know did you get annoyed
did you get annoyed with people on set
like the writers going guys [__] no I
didn't but I just laughed because they
were already number one before I got
there and they're already number one
when we were canceled so I was like why
was it number one and canceled
we're number one on Friday night we're
top we're at top 10 show and they
canceled it yeah
did a hundred apps uh I don't know you
know how this works yeah it's it's just
no Studio mine and I've been getting the
deficit or but the ratings that you had
then if it was on now they'd be like oh
this is gold insane because the there's
too many shows now too much content
there's just too much content it
overwhelms me I always say this but like
you know you go it's it's like going to
the uh
it's like you know you go to a hot dog
stand what do you want I'm I'm gonna get
a hot dog and a soda but like you go to
Jerry's Deli and there's like these
giant pages of items I know it's too
much and it's just it confuses me it's
too much hot dog
it's too much hot dog no one can win
with all that dog so what
a lot of dog but do you like the fact
that there's so many streaming platforms
now or do you like the old school where
it's less shows better content or do you
think there's better content and I think
there's better content at times but
there's also a lot more [__]
you think there's better content now
some years yeah it's interesting no no
I'm saying there's some great content
but there's more bad stuff than ever
okay here's what I would say
when you and I were popping off in the
beginning
we were blessed by the establishment
and so that's a badge of honor and it
was like it was a very narrow Lane so if
we got picked to walk in it it was like
yes
now there's less barrier to entry almost
no barrier to entry but
that makes it more democratized but it
makes which which is annoying is the
people running traditional Hollywood are
more overthinking than ever so that's
there's never been more places to
show stuff and I've never seen more
overthinking yeah but yeah I mean
there's so much you can't you can't
consume it I mean snap has networks
Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A as a network
Chick-fil-A has is getting content Tick
Tock is adding channels like it's
everywhere from from traditional to
streaming to cable to yeah dude do you
know how many Pilots CBS is gonna make
this year
I know
scripted Pilots
three what did they used to make
15 22
3.
let that sink in three
there's no pilot season anymore there
it's literally we lived in a time yeah
where it's like I'd see you at an
audition like there's these this many
shows this is already greenlit yeah I
want to get this this is now it's like I
put yourself on tape or uh meet with the
director on a zoom yeah that's what's
crazy there's no connection there's they
can't read you on a freak you know no
that's what I know that's why the
business is different from me now in my
opinion it's just not as intimate yeah
it's not as glamorous
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy
how are you guys not doing this this is
with the world the way it is
um the stigma there's not stigma on
therapy anymore everyone's talking about
mental health and life and this is good
and this means that you deserve uh
therapy uh for your life now in your
life uh it should be a part of
everyone's life if you ask me it's
helped me substantially and you know you
could talk about so many things and if
you don't they get bottled up and
unfortunately when they get bottled up
things start to manifest and they become
some other things and uh you know if you
just keep talking to someone as a
professional not me but talking to a
professional you'll see the benefits
quickly
anxious thoughts you know sometimes they
they don't seem like they're going to go
away and uh when you're trying to go to
sleep your mind's racing when you're on
a date you're anxious there's all these
things but talking through them with a
licensed therapist through better help
really will help you Ryan you still work
with Better Health I do and it's been
good it has been good for me yeah I've
noticed you've got you're calmer I
always feel better coming out of it I
mean I had one yesterday and I usually
uh
supports me through you know the next
until the next time I talk yeah and you
always feel like you have nothing to
talk about and by the end you're like I
can keep talking always always every
time therapy and better help give me a
place to get out of my negative thought
Cycles so I can find some mental and
emotional peace if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's all done online just fill out a
questionnaire which takes you a minute
and get matched with a licensed
professional therapist but you can
change them if you don't like them
um at no additional charge it's so easy
it's convenient it's flexible it's it
works to your schedule folks get a break
from your thoughts with better help
visit betterhelp.com inside today to get
10 off your first month that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside is
brought to you by neuro hacker
qualia mind that is what you have to
think of when you want to feel better
when you want to be sharper this stuff
works and I'm going to tell you about it
I use it it was accidental how I used it
and then I was surprised that something
actually works you know you take
supplements you do things and you're
like ah does this really work and
there's no scientific facts and all this
stuff but I could tell you I feel it and
I Know It Works neuro hacker has a
special deal receive a hundred dollars
off your first bottle just 1.95 a day
way less than a basic cup of coffee with
way more benefits try it for 100 days if
you aren't 100 satisfied we offer a
hundred percent money back guarantee our
sponsor neuro hacker combines 28
of some of the most research-backed
nootropic ingredients on earth into an
ultimate brain fuel formula qualia mind
it's been changing people's lives uh for
years now the formula is non-GMO vegan
gluten free and the ingredients are
meant to complement one another
factoring and each ingredient's effect
on supporting mental Clarity you know
what I love is usually when a product's
good they give you 100 day money back
guarantee and this is exactly what they
do so you have nothing to fear so if you
if you use this product and you're like
yeah Rosa mom was wrong you just get
your money back that's how easy it is
but I'm telling you you're not going to
want that 100 day money back guarantee
you have almost three months to try
neuro hackers quality of mind no
Financial Risk decide for yourself
you know and I I've taken uh drugs in
the past to help me with focus and help
me with memory and help me with Clarity
and and just give me an overall
energized feeling
um and this is
such a better product than all these
other guys that's why they're a sponsor
Ryan yeah do you have uh brain fog
memory lapses at all yeah okay well just
are you sluggish when you think about
things sometimes sometimes okay I want
you to try qualia mind I don't know why
you're not trying it I want you to start
trying this okay I have extra okay I
want I'm honestly gonna give you this
and you're gonna tell me how you feel
okay you're gonna be honest and I'm
gonna come to you with like a chalkboard
full of equations right does that happen
oh yeah look this is an all vegan
formula with potent bioavailable
ingredients this company is 100
transparent no proprietary Blends if you
don't have clear thinking in 100 days
they'll give your money back nothing
else uh out there comes close
see what one of the best brain fuel
formula on Earth can do for your mindset
go to neurohacker.com IOU for a hundred
dollars off and as a listener of inside
of you use code ious at checkout for an
extra 15 off your first purchase that's
neurohacker.com IOU to try qualiamind
with code IOU to experience
life-changing mental performance these
statements had not been evaluated by the
Food and Drug Administration the
products and statements are not intended
to diagnose treat cure or prevent any
Disease
start the sentence with the other night
I'm watching MILF Manor the reason I did
I had this friend in Indiana his name is
Nate and Nate is the guy who is a
one-word one-word response I had if I
don't talk to him for months I go you're
like hello and I go Nate what's going on
well not a whole lot I go cool man how's
the family fine cool how's Mom not bad
cool any uh anything cool going on nah
so Nate who's not very talkative
starts going I go how was last night
because I was in Indiana recently and he
goes I go what'd you do I guess well
couldn't sleep I go why not he goes I
don't know but I started watching MILF
Manor
and I go okay in this show
he says is about these 48 to 60 year old
women yeah MILFs yeah
with 20 year old men who like MILFs but
that's not even the best part of it get
ready get ready for the Twister okay
I love when they're filming when they
reveal the kids I say kids because 20s
you know you're young they're all the
MILF Sons
so the sons are having sex with
different MILFs as the MILFs having
it's a train wreck and I had to watch it
just because I was like just I have to
and I was up till four in the morning
like Nate watching effing MILF man how
many apps eight what's it on
this is my whole joke
it's on the [__] Learning Channel nah
TLC is making MILF Manor
Here's Where You're Gonna Learn kids
what you're gonna learn how to f
a 60 year old woman it's teaching
dude are you kidding me I can't make
this [__] up man wait a minute so all
the dudes who are stripping their other
milf's kids so it's one big
DNA Fest one guy's having sex with four
different MILFs one MILF is having sex
with four different guys
but I mean how much weird weirder can
you be and it's like and who created you
know what upsets me out of all this
Mastermind here's how my fed up mind
works wait one dude's taking down four
moms at least three
really yeah and one
sorry for your list if you're listening
I hope you're interested this one this
one so they put the these little uh uh
notes stick it notes on a build on a
like a a board right so they do have
sticky notes
and it says there's quotes there's like
oh not quotes but there's like um I had
sex in an elevator with my boyfriend
once in a movie theater I had this I had
this so they're going that night they
all all the young kids ask their moms
they guess what their moms put
and their mom one of the moms goes he
goes you were the elevator and she goes
no and he goes well what were you
I had sex with your best friend
and the kid almost starts crying it's
real and it's just she starts crying
because she didn't realize how upset
he'd be somehow yeah it's a train wreck
the mom told the son that she f'd her
his friend because he got upset friend
oh God could you imagine your mom
banging your best friend and your friend
yeah dude that's gonna ruin their
friendship how could you do that to me
both of you oh you [__]
anyway enough about MILF Manor but yes
the whole industry is like you know and
by the way this is why it's messed up in
my crazy mind I'm thinking
I would have come up with that and they
wouldn't have bought it yeah
that's true that's ridiculous why would
we do that but some [__] pitched it
sold the show MILF manners making
hundreds of dollars
yeah you know that's true you how many
shows do you think you've pitched since
you started
I mean I've had
two shows that I produced and starred in
and I had another six Pilots or variants
of series that I got on air six that you
were part of either wrote produced or
acted in yeah no eight but six I wasn't
on camera so let's say that's ridiculous
out of how many well like some 130 apps
some went six some went pilot but what
about the ones that didn't get made out
of shows I've probably pitched
I would say it's more it's not as many
as you think but it's one show a lot of
pitches I pitched one show 23 networks
and everyone laughed and they never
bought it so at least a hundred
different ideas I've taken around
multiple times and you got eight that
yeah about eight percent that's that's
not terrible that's really good yeah but
I never got past
to 66 like I had one more season for
syndication do you know what I'm saying
like my show would have been one more
season syndication and then boom Jamie
Jamie Kennedy experiment experiment yeah
which why was it like you know I know it
was canceled after two seasons but it
was the highest rated show it was like
it was why why did they just let it go
so quickly
I'll tell you exactly why so we got the
show we were making the show the show is
like when things in Hollywood are made
good I believe they're made kind of on a
fluke right so the show started because
Jordan who is a great guy gave you know
us very big breaks to 11.
he was running the network
and he was
he was cool he was like us he was like a
young guy you're right you're right he
loved to go to Morton's he loved to
drink wine he's always happy he knew he
knew pop music he was fun he was in and
Suzanne Daniels also young and exciting
and the WB was this new place where I've
never seen
programming for younger people let alone
a whole network dedicated to it right
that was like young y-a yeah and it was
Sarah Michelle was like you know the
poster child yeah yeah so he was a big
fan of Comedy
and he says I want you to do a tape for
the sales people and he says I want you
to go and do a prank on them and you're
going to play their a big guy you're
going to play the Network's nephew who's
got ideas for products and they're going
to film it and they filmed it
and I was in there pitching like
Coca-Cola salesperson I'm like let's go
back to the original formula bro he's
like what do you mean I'm like a little
cocaina you know like people need more
energy Red Bull's killing you let's
figure this out Colombian Coke like the
guy was like so everything was a new
product and I would just give it in the
Swiffer like all these different
products
great reactions huge thing plated at the
upfronts as a as a break in between show
and shows so they're showing you
Smallville or you know 7th Heaven
they're showing a break and this show
was shown as the break
it killed it was the perfect thing
because it was on the advertising so it
wasn't sold yet no this was just uh it
was literally it was like a a successful
interstitial to keep people happy as
they're showing new shows and keeping
the advertisers happy were you surprised
that it went this well I knew it went
well and he I knew that if it did
something he's a creative guy so it
would have been an idea it was perfect
because we played it at the place that
where people were buying the stuff and
it was their friends who were getting
pranked it was like you know 2 000
people in New York
killed and he's like we got to do a show
like that night he's like we got to do a
show okay so it takes off and boom
numbers are great and all that so yeah
then we do it takes off numbers are
great
and then second year uh we're traveling
more orders the whole season the third
year get the whole season order a ton of
cities
corporate sales
what happened was there was a corporate
restructuring and the head of I want to
say Warner Brothers
TV changed and so Jordan left a new guy
came in and asked it fat was trimmed you
cap you were one of the few that got to
stay and we got we got asked a lot of us
got acts how how hard is it for you how
hard was it for you then
when something gets canceled compared to
how you react now
uh I'll tell you a couple things what's
crazy is is that Comedy Central was
dying for the show this is gonna be good
this is a good moment for you like it
hurts
two places one ABC family and Comedy
Central Comedy Central is begging for
the show they said we're going to pair
it with Chappelle
this studio or the somebody in ownership
goes we're not going to sell it to you
unless you take all episodes produced
and they didn't they did because they
were planning on doing more seasons and
they said no we're just going to buy
what we want now and he goes you know
you have to take all future episodes and
they said
no
that deal was killed
and they sold the ABC Family
ABC Family ran it for six weeks and then
said we're changing our mandates
so it was gone in six weeks Comedy
Central meanwhile Chappelle blows up
because of reruns because of the DVDs
would have got that second window I
believe
so when it was canceled though I was
doing a lot I was doing movies I was
doing stuff so I was like okay it was a
good run an amazing springboard I'll
look at my next thing
but
when it went down I had a few other
things go down and then I was definitely
bummed would I be as bummed as I would I
would not be nearly as bummed now but
then I was pretty damn bombed like would
it how did do you remember the feeling
of like you know just waking up every
day was hard was that are you that kind
of guy who gets depressed like I deal
with depression I deal with anxiety but
you sort of like can't get out of bed
I'm a failure is that where your mind
goes uh I remember I had a series of a
few things bomb and I definitely I
remember I was having parties at my
house a lot it was me and my buddy stu
okay yeah so Stu would come over and he
would bring people and we would hang out
I remember drinking like wine and I was
I remember eating what I remember just
not giving a [__] so I was
self-destructive uh
yeah I wasn't like I was like let's get
back on the horse but I was like this is
I needed to vegetate so I was just yeah
I was doing whatever I wanted to do and
it wasn't I wasn't distracting myself
but I wasn't exactly being proactive and
I did that for about eight months eight
months I'm just but like going and
gorging on Sushi coming back going to a
club hanging out all night a lot of six
filling the void oh yeah a lot of six
ammers do you know what I'm saying right
no we've all been there
inside you is brought to you by rocket
money
how have everyone
is that the right how how hasn't
everyone
taken this app and used it in their life
rocket money is just saves you money I I
don't know what else to say
um I have so many subscriptions over the
years that I forgot that I had because I
I got this one fluvly
uh streamer for 9.99 because I wanted to
watch Ryan's greatest hits for a second
I thought fluid was real yeah it's not
um and then I forgot about it and all of
a sudden I'm a hundred dollars in and
I'm like well I don't want to pay this
but you're screwed rocket money will
help you rock rocket money will take
care of all this crap this extra money
that you're spending and save you money
there's subscriptions for things
everywhere these days streaming services
fitness programs
um sometimes it feels impossible to keep
tabs on what you're paying for every
month and that's why I'm a huge fan of
Rocket money rocket money is a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps you lower your bills
all in one place with rocket money you
can easily cancel the ones you don't
want with just one press of a button no
more long hold times or annoying emails
with customer service rocket money does
all the work for you and that is so true
I don't know how many times I've tried
to call some and I couldn't get the
1-800 number it wasn't a 1-800 number
and then I'm like I want to cancel this
and you don't know if they cancel it
you're like am I going to still be
charged it's stressful Ryan you know
rocket money can even negotiate to lower
your bills for you no by up to 20
percent you believe that wow all you
have to do is take a picture of your
bill and Rocket money takes care of the
rest yeah rocket money also lets you
monitor all your expenses in one place
recommends custom budgets based on your
past spending and they'll even send you
notification when you've reached your
spending limits with over 3 million
users and Counting rocket money
customers have saved an average of 720
dollars a year stop wasting money on
things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions manage your money
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
inside that's
rocketmoney.com
inside
rocketmoney.com slash inside this
message is sponsored by discover did you
know you could reduce the number of
unwanted calls and emails with online
privacy protection the latest Innovation
from discover discover will help
regularly remove your personal info like
your name and address from 10 popular
people search websites that could sell
your data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection yeah and it's people
don't realize
how
depressed
you can get like I'm always about going
to the next thing but people don't
realize that you give your soul to
something
yeah when it is stopped
it is like you're getting cut off it's
like instant that's like why reviews can
be so brutal you work a year a year and
a half on something and people just
lacerate it with the swipe of a pen and
sometimes they do it because for some
reason they don't like you yeah oh big
time or they're trying to get clicks or
they're trying to be funny it's like I
always tell it man you can't really
judge me until you walk in his shoes and
it's like our our business is incredible
we are so fortunate yes but what did we
do to get there what have we given up
what have we you know we are laser-like
focused I didn't and have normal
relationships I don't have normal
friendships like I don't have hobbies I
don't have like dinner nights this is
what you do this is yeah there's like
what do you like to do for fun where's
the there is no fun my life is my fun
like when I'm on set it's the funnest
thing ever but like to get there is a
[__] marathon and people don't
realize that they're like oh you know
what I'm saying so we are animals and we
cannot stop until we keep going and even
Robin Williams brilliant he's like he's
like
eighty percent of our of our job is
getting the job
and that's Robin Williams
yeah I mean some people like you know in
the industry a lot of people will you
know do things for fame I just want to
be famous and then people do it because
they just love doing it I know guys like
yourself I don't care what I'm doing I
want to work I want to be on a show I
want to be acting I want to just do I'll
keep doing it and that's what they love
and it's
I I feel like it is so much a part of
them
that that's all they've known and that's
all they know maybe that
they can't change that's like if they
don't work they're not going to be happy
yeah I've definitely through covid now
have had an adjustment and through our
business which has changed drastically I
believe in the last six years but now
they're like for instance I have a show
I'm going out with with another guy
who's very known because it used to be
just you pitch an idea like and you
would just talk at lunch and be like
okay write it up and blah blah blah
that's nice yeah yeah you know how gone
those are so now you gotta stack your
deck so I'm with another guy who's a big
producer he has a deal we're going out
and out of 10 networks so far
four
have passed to hear it four pass to just
hear it to hear it four
now you remember what we said earlier
about the numbers four don't even want
to hear it
now why do they not like me is there
mandates is there you know what I'm
saying like and this is a person that's
also very successful so it's
wild like that is and that just like
hurtful well no it's just like if I
can't even get to the table when I've
already eaten and [__] done
everything like
well I mean I'm looking I'm not invited
anymore yeah no it's like it's like and
and for what I'm fighting for a two
market share like to get through all
these hoops for less of a viewership I'd
rather just go on Tick Tock you know
yeah but also like why to me it's like
hey he's had a lot of success he's done
some successful things let's just hear
him out it's it's 20 minutes well
because people are now you know there's
a lot listen
how can I say how can I say this say it
there is a lot of
different mandates now and so sometimes
where you and I I've there are certain
things when people just don't want to
see me for because of who I am
do you know what I'm saying and I think
that's okay but it's like yo I was it's
not the best man win as much as it used
to be do you agree with that absolutely
I think that like if you have a great
idea I don't give a [__] who who did it
whose idea is it let's let's let's hear
it let's uh and also they're doing a
disservice maybe to their Network
because it could be something that could
be very beneficial to them yes
so it's it's changed a lot and it's just
like
so I mean it's just it's just the
ratings aren't the same you know
it's just a wild time so the business to
me is lost a little bit of a shine and
I'm not bitter man I'm like lucky have a
great life yeah and I'm lucky I've
become somewhat of an entity so I can
always keep going but it's just like you
know I either self tape
or I'll get an indie you know what I
mean and hopefully one of those in these
are great hopefully one of them pops
yeah I mean look it just happened which
I love them I'm sure you're good friends
with them with uh uh uh why do you just
blow his name Simon Rex Simon's killing
it and think about it beautiful for a
while Simon was just kind of like you
didn't hear about him and all of a
sudden a little indie movie
yeah boom he's getting work everywhere
and he was phenomenal and he deserves it
and I love him and I'm so happy for him
yeah but look that's look every every
big Hollywood Story they want to see the
underdog they want to see the guy that
wants to get that gets back on top
that's what a lot of movies are I don't
you know what's funny is a lot of those
movies aren't made anymore it's all just
either you know dude how many auditions
would you go on for a movie in a week
back in the day at least a couple or a
TV show
you would go on two or three auditions a
day for a movie think about this okay
Disney right Hollywood pictures Buena
Vista three different divisions each
making what 12 13 movies a year 38 39
movies okay I remember going on three
movies in a day for them
find like two in one week I had like six
movie auditions now what does Disney
make total
eight movies a year 400 million a movie
and they're usually animated or
something well some are animated but
then the rest are like 12 stars super
yeah right so there's the mid-level to
eight to ten million dollar movie is
done
and so it's just like how can we make
this huge piece of Pop Culture Americana
how can we turn it into a ride how can
we do it like where are the urban
legends those are going to streaming
where are the screams I don't would
screen be made you know the original
idea you know I I see
you know I have to really search because
I don't use Rotten Tomatoes as a gauge
anymore because it's absolute [__]
yes because and everybody who knows
movies or anything about movies
next time you look at a movie and it
says 95 watch that movie and also look
at the audience score which is usually
significantly lower look at the audience
store not Rotten Tomatoes I saw there's
something completely messed up with that
because the movies that I find good A
lot of times are like the 52 58 yeah but
the 90s are always crap
or not always crap but they're always
they're never they're mostly not as good
as you know these critics say they are
so you're saying the critics are
conspiring together I don't know I like
I like uh conspiracy theories I will say
that I don't know I don't know I don't
know I'm saying I'm not saying this the
audiences will pick a movie that works
that they may not like but the odd it'll
be killing with the audience but you can
manipulate an audience by saying 95 on
Rotten Tomatoes and everybody rushes to
see it and you make your money and then
they're like yeah that was like a 75
maybe maybe a 70. man that wasn't a 90
who's doing that and they're all
they're [__] all like that and then
I'll dig on shutter to find some little
horror independent movie from 2007
called isolation which is like an
independent movie of The Thing an alien
combined and I'm like going [__] yeah
um
dude you just woke up
I did all right before you got here I
did too but you just woke ah yeah I just
like man I I was I like it it does
it's passion because I just like I just
I really buy into it I'm like God they
can't be like wow 70 critics said this
200 critics gave it a 98. It's gotta be
great yeah I'm like what am I missing
and maybe I just don't know know good
anymore maybe I'm just so jaded maybe
I'm just not I don't know what good is
anymore maybe it's hard
I don't know I don't know Bro think
about it when's the last time you see a
comedy
I can't tell you the last comedy that I
saw oh MILF Manor was pretty funny
exactly but that's what you're going for
your comedy when's the last big comedy
movie they're not making them they're
not green lighting them
yeah you're right they're not
let me ask you this I like this this is
good you do this is great okay good I
like that you're yelping it in the
middle of it what yelping it guys five
stars Yelp
um
I'm just like looking back like I I read
like you know when you first started you
were doing extra work you're working Red
Lobster
do you ever look back and go dude with
all the success and some failures
whatever that hey man look I'm I'm here
still I'm here look what I've done are
you able to do that or you kind of don't
look back and you're just looking
forward
uh well I love Denzel and he's always
like my favorite movie is my next one
and I think that's a brilliant mindset
um
but no I definitely because of all the
stuff we're talking about I definitely
feel like I don't sit in Revel in my
life but I definitely know I'm fortunate
and I'm like
I'm a thing I know how much money I have
like in terms of like what's safe and
I'm like no the part of legacies I've
been a part of like I've been a part of
some pretty cool legacies yeah I've also
done some you know movies that only come
in out on Pakistan Redbox you know right
these things happen and but I do feel
that I'm very
I'm I yeah I feel good like I
many people tell me that our generation
is the last generation of true Fame
and after us it was all social media and
different and there have been people
that come out Legacy stars like Jennifer
Lawrence and Channing Tatum yeah graphic
actors yes but not as many as they were
now it was like there's a lot of social
media stars in there if you don't have a
following you're saying then you're you
know you're not a movie star
well no like we we were traditional Fame
made picked by The Establishment right
we didn't have any built-in audience
yeah or like we didn't know what we were
we didn't have a video that go viral for
us like you know slipping on something
or you know a big prank or you know what
I'm saying yeah so yeah I get it good
and good for them no good for them but
like General right like Jen Ortega now
is the next Mega star you know she's a
new Legacy star but again there's not
many people of this caliber where in our
day more people would come out you could
have a couple people pop and so
I'm very fortunate that I have made a
name and I I don't sit and revel in it
but I do know that yeah I've done
something and I'm lucky yeah are you are
your parents still with you no in the
past but thank you for asking when
uh last seven years my dad was about six
and a half years ago my mom was about
three years ago I'm sorry that's okay
how hard was that it was I mean well my
dad was easier because he was going down
and then my mom was also going down and
I mean they lived almost 90. so I was
Elite but it doesn't make it easier no
but it's it's a I have some you know
some issues with my mom's death but I've
processed it a lot and issues like how
just you know having these last
conversations that I didn't really get
to have but we had them throughout her
life but you know you want I was there
so much and we tried to
I tried to time it my sisters tried to
time it you know and then she just went
in her sleep which I guess is a good
thing but two I want you know I was
there with my dad my whole family was
holding my dad's hands looking in his
eyes as he died that's like
insane but it's like literally Picture
Perfect Charles Dick and death like it
was like
like so people like dude you understand
how rare that is and my mom I wasn't
there so but again I was so spoiled if I
could say that with my father's death
that I felt like my mother's death I
felt like oh I wish I was there
yeah but you know we I'd gone back and
forth so many times and I canceled stuff
and then I was like I gotta keep my life
going so I tried to schedule it and so
well you know that they were proud of
you right I I hope so I really hope so
do they tell you that they say I love
you Jamie um they did during my as my
career was going and and there were
moments but I didn't have that end of
life conversation with my mom which I'm
kind of bummed about but we had it
throughout her life yeah
um but my sisters will say they look at
all the stuff they said about you
but you know you questions I think let
me ask you this this is a this is
selfish
and I don't know how to articulate it
take your time
but we've covered a lot of things but
when your parents are dying yeah or even
before they're dying where are you
almost like saying you know I'll be okay
I'm prepared I'm like I feel like and
it's weird like I feel like I'm gonna be
fine I'll know how to deal with it I
don't want to happen and then it hits
and it's completely different or were
you sort of like what was the
juxtaposition what was the feeling
before and the feeling after
could you prepare yourself for it
um do you have both your parents I do
okay that's beautiful it is but there's
you know there's there's a lot of
history there's a lot of things that
will never be talked about and they just
won't be okay and um but I have forgiven
and um
I think I'm fine with it but my uncle
who's a psychologist retired so whatever
but he said to me he goes I said
something you know about my mom
and he goes you know
because death got brought up she goes
you know he has I mean you know you
might want to you should definitely see
a therapist and talk to your therapist
about this and I go about what
I just don't know how well you're gonna
do when your mom passes and I go
what do you what are you saying I mean
it's like
because I he knows the history and knows
all these things and and I'm like since
you know all this why are you saying
that
but he thinks it's going to affect me
differently than I think which kind of
scares me
[Music]
um
so I'm not exactly sure what to do but
you know because there's a lot of
resentment in my family there's a lot
but I've also again let it go as much as
I can a lot of therapy a lot of that
stuff but there comes a time when it
happens you're like and I you know she
always said this and this was
manipulative she said you only have one
mother
[Music]
um
and as a kid you think about that you
only have one mother you only have one
mother no matter how good how bad how
complicated how whatever
you do and it's unfair
to be told that to think that mm-hmm
so I guess for me I'm just you know
you know if there was sort of a before
feeling and an after feeling and what
that was if that makes sense
yes my father was a huge smoker
so he told us how many packs a day
two and a half three I'm talking
viceroy's bro for years
decades he started when he was 13 he
died when he was 86. bro
deep in the game like he should be uh he
would probably live to 180 if he didn't
smoke
so at like 83 he said I got a little
cancer he called me one day and he said
little him and my mom called and he's
like I got a little thing on my lung and
I said what are you gonna do he goes
nothing
and I'm like why and he's like I don't
want to go through that so that was the
hardest time
processing that you're going to lose a
parent again I had him for 43 years up
into that point and I was the youngest
of six kids and they were already older
parents so I was already understood that
I had older parents not like other kids
so I that started the clock uh we got
him a lot of different therapies and
natural stuff and he did them but he
didn't care he was he was done living
before we were done letting him live and
that's what I learned is you got to let
people live their own life it's like we
were trying our hardest to save him and
he was like people have to want to be
saved yeah and he had lived and my dad
was a beautiful soul complicated figure
but he slowly slowly went and I had an
amazing doctor for him because I was
doing a show called heartbeat on NBC so
it was based on this amazing female
cardiologist and so she hooked me up
with the best doctors in the world and
so I'd have them come in
but we you know he slowly went so after
I got through that first shock of him
telling me that
you know the day was gonna come
it became a love beautiful Fest I had a
gig I ran back because my sister's like
it's not good
made it back and he didn't go that day
but he went a week later
so like I said there's the death was
beautiful so you're saying you were like
like I did with my grandfather you were
mourning him as he was slowly yes
letting him know and to be quite frankly
I was talking to him trying to be deep
and he was like
okay
can you give me my coffee like like
you're like yeah like Hey Dad I love you
okay great ah can you take me to the
toilet like people are just trying to
survive which made me feel better you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah uh so
I I enjoyed him my other boy his dad was
dying same time it kind of died similar
so
I enjoyed it my money what did you say
my other buddy his father was dying the
same time and so we were both coming on
right
so
when he died
it was sad but it was a celebration but
I felt bad for my mother yeah because my
mother lost her hip this was her hip
58 maybe I think 60 Years bro
I was able to throw them a huge 50th
anniversary party and all my family was
in a great event I think they did I
think it was either 59 or 60 60 Years
bro that's
unheard of you and I we can't be
commended for what 60 seconds you know
it's like different world so
his was a beautiful passing my mother's
we knew she was gonna go to
but she kept coming back
and I filmed it was filming a CSI
episode and I told them and they're like
they were so sweet they rearranged it so
I could go back I go back she didn't
pass I doing a stand-up show I quit went
back and we she just kept and she lasted
for a good four more years jeez and so
it was incredible and they say that
people will stay alive for you you know
and we give them that energy but she
literally at the end of her life this is
not like she was almost like a head like
she was just like
hey you put that blueberry in my mouth
like I mean I was like so she all lost
functions
so
it was almost a relief for her like I
said I have some things of like not
holding her hand Not Looking In Her Eyes
not saying Mom I love you talk to you on
the other side those moments but again
people say that's a perfect ending but
I felt almost
a relief for her pain I know that sounds
crazy she was all she was a month that's
that's being human yeah and and then um
but here how I felt after that dude dude
dude I'll take two things I felt like
I'm alone because I have brothers and
sisters but you know we have some good
relationships some complicated
and I have a huge family but I don't I
talk to them more now like cousins and
different people that's nice I felt like
I'm alone
but I'm also free
yeah do you know what I'm saying I do I
I know exactly what you're saying and
I've been my yeah I've been my parents
parents since I was about 28 years old
me too I've been taking care of them
well my mom yeah so it was like I'm like
I'm already kind of been my own parent
and like for the first year I was like
who am I gonna like no one's give I'm
always doing my own money it's like you
don't have to worry anymore no like it's
almost like as as bad as it might sound
it's like them passing is sort of also a
relief for them but also a relief for
you and you can not have to worry and
not have to be there all the time and
not have to like yeah it's emotional and
exhausting and it's like you know it's
almost it's crippling and there's a
there is a quantum entanglement like
when my mother died I felt her pull my
mother's a very strong presence you know
gave me my moral back what my father did
too but my mother was like
made me a good boy you know what I'm
saying like I do obey the laws in a lot
of ways but I'm also very flashback at
the system but she gave me morals my
mother would never steal a penny and so
when she died I felt
this presence leave me but I do know
that she's imbued me with that these
beliefs that will never leave me in like
you said I'm free to like literally like
I'm Kung Fu remember Kung Fu like walk
to Earth
now you're ready to live I mean we live
I mean we live but I know it's really
like let it Let It Go and live more yeah
like sometimes you don't do things in
your life because you're like what would
my mother think but then part of me is
like yep well I'm she's not here but
then part of me still like well my
mother like that my brother says that
he'll say like with mom like that like
don't do that
so it's still changes
let it be exact good Lord there's a lot
that's amazing too there's a lot of
feelings but at the end of the day
I'm going to tell you this make your
piece bro I can't tell you this make
your p Ace look in your mother's eyes
tell her you love her and then
find make sure that she's proud of you
that what you've done what you've
achieved and going on this world and
then just clean your side of the street
that's all I can tell you
give me emotional Kennedy
and
and time will heal time heals like there
are certain things my mother's death
that I was like a little bit still like
I said unsettled with time has been the
great regulator
and time makes the lovers feel like they
got something real but you and me we got
nothing but time and time won't give me
time
you got to pay royalty but the
Brilliance of George Michael actually
it's Culture Club it's um I mean uh
Michael George oh boy do you see that
that's the 5G listen I love you and I
want you to do that it's I will I wasn't
a deterrent it wasn't me deflecting but
it was but I I'm still I hear you um you
said something about eight minutes ago
you said you know you and I were single
why are we single this and that you're
52 I'll be 50. I have a girlfriend now
how long a couple years
that's awesome
well let me ask you uh do you feel like
there was is a pressure in your later
years where people you'd always hear
whether it be your mom well we could
have a single combo go ahead whether
it's your mom your dad your your brother
whatever did you feel like your friends
were saying like yeah this is great you
know you're single a lot of times now
you're not but
you don't want to be alone when you get
older that's that's the reason everybody
says that's the reason you just gotta
find someone so you're not alone I want
to find someone that I want gives me the
reason not to want to be alone yeah
yeah
so what's your question
it really is more rhetorical
um I would say look
the death there's a couple things here
dude we're going here it's like the
deaths have changed me
and
covid
that's me give me another perspective
and our business the way I believe it's
changed is giving me a lot of
perspective so I remember I would walk
around my house
and I'd be alone
and you know we would have different
friends come over
and I would be like I love my freedom
but yes our life can be I love my alone
time but our life can also be lonely do
you know what I'm saying that's why you
see people hanging around with people
that aren't exactly good for them just
because they want somebody next to them
you know
so
for me I've gone through a lot and my
girl has been there through the hell
that's when you know and she's been
she's the most beautiful soul and she's
and I don't talk about it publicly so
this is again I'm sharing this with you
but she's you know what she is dude more
than anything
she's sweet
and I love a sweet person and it makes
you sweeter doesn't it totally I like I
tell always tell her this I would always
tell any woman in LA
I don't kick puppies
and you know what I mean by that these
women they come out they try to be so
tough and [__] you know and it's a
cover and I'm like be vulnerable
be vulnerable I will not take advantage
of that and but some guys do yes you're
correct you are and so that's why
there's like a lot of trust right I
agree right but and I guess me yeah
you're right and that's not fair to me
to say but it's also fair to me to say
like there are certain people that just
have walls up and it's like yes let's
build a trust here and you'll realize
that maybe your wall and once when the
walls come down
You're vulnerable I will protect you but
you're right there are monsters out but
more importantly what I think you're
saying too is which I'm getting from
from you is that
um the only time you're ever going to
really find true love is when you are
vulnerable yeah you're both
Let Down the Walls and let each other in
and take a chance I think that's what
I'm gathering is that you know my
therapist
I went to this place because I was
really depressed and stuff and I just
wasn't a good place a couple years ago
rehab it's like a treatment center but I
wasn't on drugs or alcohol and I've
never been that how long did you do
three weeks in Malibu no in Connecticut
wow and um uh Zach Levi actually
recommended it to me because we have a
lot of deep conversations and [__] and
um
uh this guy this old guy Dr Kessler yeah
and he goes and after all these sessions
weeks he was
you know what I think and I go
I I don't I'd like to hear it
he says
I think when you allow someone to love
you
that's when you're gonna be happy that's
when you're gonna Thrive allow someone
to love you you don't trust it
um
and it was like I cried right in front
of him I was like oh my God I have tries
I know why I know why we've talked about
all these um okay look
this is amazing I mean I love this this
is this is good so you didn't think it
was going to go so deep did you
I don't know well with comedians mostly
you think oh we're just gonna joke back
but I like to like this is real [__] I
like that yeah
wait
okay can I comment on that yeah
here's what happened because your mommy
issues
are that's what's affecting sure sure
and
but I will say this I it's I never
expect it to be in a relationship I'm
like you you know what I'm saying we
live our life
we to dawdle around the world
um and I'm in one and I'm fortunate you
know but like again I've passed 50. I
have a lot of things happen to me and
and like the universe put me and her
together
also you told me back in back in the day
I had no idea that you you've talked
about it openly but you have you have
always had a kidney thing I have kidney
I only have one kidney what now what
does that mean because you could
obviously live with one kidney you're
here with us right now yeah but is it do
you have to be more thoughtful of how
you eat and drink because you only have
one kidney I think so but you don't my
doctor doesn't say you know you can live
with a quarter kidney
you can live with a quarter kidney and
so I have one whole kidney and you only
it's fine why did they remove the other
one because it was there was uh
something happening it's something
that's something called a ureter and
that was twisted up and through that uh
urine was not escaping throughout years
a tiny percentage of urines dated my
kidney which basically poisoned it and
killed it so it was killed by not
getting rid of the waste and you didn't
know it you could have probably
corrected it many years before that
definitely how old were you when this
happened uh 24 when I had the procedure
but I was feeling weird for up since I
was about 16 but little bits every like
twice a year I'd get a weird pain and it
would go away did you think you were
gonna die
uh the kidney I mean I guess but not
terribly because my doctor was so
confident but I definitely felt like
what's that mean only have one kidney
and he's like you don't need more than
one the quality was some German I don't
know if that's German but he was a
sweetest guy and he educated me so and
then I would party and do everything but
I don't I haven't drank in a while not
because of like I'm sober or anything
just because I was saw myself in some I
saw myself on did an episode of Lucifer
and I was so puffy and I'm like I gotta
like easy on the [__] boozy so I
don't really drink in a while I'm not
saying I want it again
but I've really become like you know I
just kind of like I like to do
activities yeah you know you know what's
funny is I was interviewing someone and
their best friend was um Helen Hunt
mm-hmm
and uh they she was talking about seeing
herself because she's older now she's
not like 20s 30s 40s she's in her 50s
and she saw herself the director showed
her some of her scenes
and she went back to her best friend
Helen Hunt
and she said
Helen said how was the movie How She
Goes
I saw some footage and I I look so old
and Helen Hunt looked at her and goes
we're dying
yeah we're dying we're getting old yeah
you're gonna look older because you're
older yeah
that's uh I love that that really hit me
I was like wow that's brilliant yeah
I love [__] like that
um you know you've talked about it ad
nauseam but like I I just want to know
because I don't know the story you
auditioned for Wes Craven for the scream
stuff yeah how many times
first time is for Lisa Beach back in New
York no it's here CBS Radford oh
and she was looked at me the whole time
and she's like
that was really good
and like you know people say that but
you don't know right and then she goes
could you come back Thursday to meet the
director and I said
yeah are you serious she goes yeah
and then I left and I didn't you know
didn't know it was gonna reel or not and
Katie Mason my agent
called and said honey you're going back
Thursday so then I went back met Wes
very quiet yep I worked with him too
yeah did the scenes and then he was like
that was good
and I was like does that mean it's good
he's like that was really good and so
then I was like boom then did you know
all your lines inside out no that's
what's great bro you can look at my
audition tape I'm holding the script I'm
looking down I'm improvising do you
remember when directors like Wes why
they're the greatest because they play
it was an audition it was play and he
saw yeah he saw in essence Dave when I
got three kings David Russell made me
read for three different characters he
goes go to the bathroom and learn new
stuff okay and come back man I don't
like that go to the bathroom and learn
this one but you didn't learn it you
kind of just I just did it and then we
improvised we did it Essence it's
Essences you know now if you miss one
line on a [__] self tape on a zoom
you're dead to them it's like I I mean
that's the difference between autors and
corporate you know creative of art
corporations can't make art authors do
you know Wow TV art is not made by
committee that is my opinion so it's
made by singular Vision so I went I
auditioned and then the crazy [__] is is
that
I was filming Romeo and Juliet
and they my agent called and says I have
two auditions for you next Saturday I
was like six weeks down there and they
go you gotta get back here but they're
not flying you back
one was a screen test for a movie the
past
and another one was a movie called
scream
and I went in and I killed at the past
and then I went for scream and I think I
did really good but I had my hair was
pink
and the whole there was like eight
people in the room and they were like
and I remember Marianne and she's like
your hair
it's pink
and I go I know and she goes why and I
go because I'm doing Romeo Juliet I'm
doing with Leo Leo you know Romeo and
Juliet is going to be a big bass and
she's like Okay and like I'll just was
like I'm gonna lose this [__] job I'm
like we could die I'll pay for the die
job oh I can diet you know what I mean
like I'm rapping in two weeks
long story you know long we can podcasts
to tell you how I got the job but it was
getting it losing it getting it losing
it getting it losing it Wes loved me the
producers love me the studio one in the
name I wasn't a name back and forth back
and forth and then Wes God Rest his soul
you know he said this is my guy did you
did you keep in touch with us or not
really all the time he was um he was a
father another father figure a beautiful
soul uh I can tell you multiple stories
about him he would have dinner parties
he lived one of the coolest things I
remember about this business was
he lived up on yeah I know he signed in
beautiful
he lived up on solar
Solar Drive
big views beautiful views
and his next to get to his little
section he had to drive to like two
other houses
so it was like a live day this little
like uh what is that called like a
cul-de-sac yeah
and Pauly Shore
lived in the other one
and Paulie when Scream 2 opened up to
number one he put a huge Banner
from across the cul-de-sac house to
house and said congratulations screamed
to like biggest opening of November in
history like it was like the biggest
opening of November or something he says
congratulations you killed it it was so
[__] beautiful that's awesome and
I'll never forget it and Wes loved it
and he kept it up there
you know and these are the stories that
you don't hear right
and because Paulie knows he knows how
hard it is to make a a movie let alone a
hit movie
and so Wes would have these dinner
parties and he would have different
people from like Heather from she's
coming on the podcast oh that's amazing
yeah he had Angela Bassett from uh you
know Vampire in Brooklyn
uh he would have Robert he would have
different of us from Scream
and his place was like this
where he would have memorabilia from all
different
is different movies and uh
next to his bed
was this little frame of something
and it was I said what is that and he
said that's my hack license
in a hack license is a license to drive
a cab in New York City
and it's sad you know Wes Craven and
lazy cat whatever 1971 1972 And I said
why do you keep that next to your bed
and he says because when I get up every
morning I look at it
and I say to myself this is something I
never want to go back to
and the fear
that he would have to drive a cab again
fueled him to make movies
I'm doing that tomorrow four million
dollar house huge Legacy and he still
has that to remind him dude not only
that like the fear of that license put
the fear in him and he scared us he's
got three different universes at least
nightmare scream and Hills Have Eyes
three different universes that he
created independently
unbelievable you're coming back
because you have so many stories I I
like we haven't even I I have a service
I never even look at this but it's like
I there's so many things I want to talk
to you about but
um look this is these are questions
rapid fire from my patrons these are
patrons who support the podcast I love
you guys go to patreon.com inside of you
join patreon Health podcast Leanne what
do you enjoy most about being part of
the scream franchise and what is your
all-time favorite horror movie
can I guess your favorite horror movie
yeah Shining
oh it's a good one it's right there or
alien
it's a good one uh you're leaving on
Exorcist oh yeah that's a good one
Exorcist might be the scariest but
shining is really good too you know what
the scariest part of The Exorcist is
when she's at the uh on the bed and the
priest looks at and goes
he asked
quad gnome in me he asked and she goes
and he goes and then also the the
dresser the the the drawer that opens
and he goes do that again
time
no do it now in time
I was like oh
I want to freak out I love dude you're a
pleasure I forgot how much of a pop
culture junkie how about The Shining
when uh Nicholson she runs in the room
uh what's her name uh in The Shining uh
Shelley Duvall for character though
Shelley Duvall Wendy okay
and uh
she runs it because Jack Jack there's
someone in the cell in the hotel
they heard Tammy they hurt Danny and
Jack just goes
you out of your [__] mind
one of my favorite old-time moments Jack
moments give me the bat Wendy
not gonna hurt you yeah you didn't let
me finish my sentence Wendy said I'm not
gonna hurt you I'm just gonna bash your
brains I'm gonna bash them right the
[__]
does he do a lot of Impressions I don't
do them all the time all the time bro
I can make a living maybe why don't you
what are you doing stand up for a little
bit I was but then I got kind of distant
was disenchanted you were going up I
would miss you you're on different shows
you were going you know what it is it's
it's a sort of uh what's hard for me is
you have you aren't under valued Talent
and part of it's my fault I think I let
me get in the way I don't know bro I do
I think I think I let me get in the way
of a lot of things in life and that's
something I need to get over but it's
it's a it's a process the older I get in
the last couple years have just kind of
given me the uh
the ability to start feeling like I
don't need to do something because it
makes my agent happy I don't have to do
something because everybody thinks I
should yeah I need to do things because
I like doing them I enjoy doing them I
want most importantly I want to do them
you know and that seems so easy like
most people go I don't give a [__] what
they think I'll do what I want you know
it's taken me a little more time uh this
is Ray H what project have you worked on
that you were the most proud of
that's too hard to answer I know it's
too hard but what's the one thing that
you think or maybe the most proud of and
the most fun
uh listen there's a lot of babies that
I've been part of and giving birth to
some fortunate so I'm not trying to hurt
anything but I would say Malibu's
I'm really proud of because that was an
idea that I had and to Shepherd it all
the way from my idea to concept of
script to sail to movie to successful
movie to now being this like cold hit
that made me feel good and it validated
me as a person to say oh okay my idea is
actually
awesome yes I love that Kendrick f
just want to give a shout out to the
movie bong water
great cast and your character Tommy was
legendary any funny memories from the
set
um wow that's like 26 years ago it's a
deep cut I would say it was just an
amazing cast it was Luke Wilson Jack
Brittany Murphy God Rest her soul Scotty
Khan
um why am I not on your podcast I just
started it I'm gonna start having people
what's it called hate to break it to you
with Jamie Kennedy dude
um where can they find it it's not out
yet no it's on it's on YouTube but it's
but I'm it's gonna be everywhere but
it's on YouTube dude check it out from
God's sakes uh but
um funny story if buying water was great
I don't know I can't do it just remember
you could also watch thong water on TLC
it's out now
House of Joelle love Malibu's Most
Wanted do you think that type of satire
could be done today
uh
it should be it's needed more than ever
but no because of political correctness
how do you deal with haters right now
have you learned to deal with haters do
you still do you still read reviews do
you still give a [__] as much or does it
still kind of hurt you no matter what
don't give a [__] as much
definitely if they catch you on a bad
day as you know
because we all can have a bad day
they'll sting you I think a hater
affects you the most when you're when
you're at a point where you're most
insecure about what they're hating on
about you so if you're insecure about
something and they Zing you
you will have a bad day with it but I
don't let them validate me the best way
to do it is if you find something that
really hates on you you click their
profile and if they have 22 followers
and they're their icon is an egg
then you know you know what I'm saying
like what am I worrying about yeah but
if it's like a you know I get surprised
and this could be a whole other pod I
can't believe the amount of people
within our business sometimes that hate
on
other like us like I as an actor I would
never hate on another actor let alone
publicly
but people do that now and that's weird
that's cannibalism
yeah
those to me are people that never had
success because it's a painful existence
yeah that all they have is to let's
let's hurt someone else let's throw hate
out there because that's that somehow
fills something for them you know
briefly
um what's next I'm on tour so you can
see me go on my way yeah where are you
in the next few cities.com go to
jamiekennedy.com every week I'm on tour
what do you and I'm on at cons I'm
always going to cons yeah you gotta come
I know you do them I do cons too but we
just haven't crossed paths yeah what
what is uh is an hour long when people
come see you you do yeah and what's like
can you give us a taste of something
that you talk about
or is it something you say for them I
mean you know that's a whole bit but
like I don't know we want to talk like
uh
they know they could you could go on my
Instagram you see some of my Rants and
do you like talking about you you're
very self-deprecating I have yes I have
moments like that right what how do you
deal with bombing does it just not phase
you anymore oh it totally faces me you
don't like when you bomb well I don't
like I don't mind bombing as much but I
hate it when the audience hates that I
bomb and they think I stink but it's not
that I stink it's just that I'm trying
new things but you have to bomb in the
right atmosphere because if you bomb
when it's a big show they're like yeah
we paid for this we don't want to see
you ever get booed
uh I definitely get some hate for sure I
get heckled a lot still yeah yeah
what do they what what people say uh
you're not funny you suck and what do
you say
um I said well I bought two houses
[Laughter]
exactly well it's not like a disc of
like because I did that I'm better than
you it's because I bought the houses
using the talent which you said I am not
you know what I'm saying like right I
didn't buy them as a plumber I bought
them being funny which is that I'm not I
love it I love it you know Dice Clay had
one of the best lines a long time ago he
would never be here right now doing this
his comedy from yesteryear but he still
does it but dice is up every week is he
yeah he's still doing the same [__] I
don't know but he's he he dice is one of
our edgiest Comics oh so he still does
that same [__] oh I didn't know that
he's everywhere I gotta go see him but
anyway he I remember he was an Arsenio
Hall in Circa 1990 something okay and
Arsenio was talking to him and this guy
yells out get out of here we don't want
you here
and he goes
look at you huh
you're the type of guy that gets out of
the shower to take a piss
why don't you turn your teeth around and
bite your throat
I was [__] well I love when they have
a comeback like shut the hell up yeah
you know I'm up here
you know as people don't understand like
you're up there like it's you're alone
and you're doing your thing yeah let him
do his thing let her do her thing but
now more than ever Michael
social media
entitlement
it's three things it's be if you were
raised with social media you are raised
that you have an opinion and you could
tell it to people and it matters okay
and then it's able to spread through
social media and then gen Z no offense
the humor Gene is gone I love gen Z
because they're compassionate generation
and they're much more inclusive which is
beautiful
but they don't get sarcasm no and I
would like to teach them a little bit of
sarcasm and they can teach me a little
bit more about being sensitive
I like how he thinks
I'm not saying I'm surprised by how good
of a guest you've been but I'm surprised
at how much better it even is that I
thought it would be oh thank you no
because this is what it's about like
people it's it's interesting everything
we're talking about is interesting or
you know uh you know you talk about you
know death it just I really enjoyed this
thanks buddy I I haven't seen you in I
know a lot too long we I want to meet
the girl yeah will you come back yeah I
don't say that very often I just really
enjoyed it you're very open I I like
that I feel like I could say anything
and you you know and that makes me want
to go there's still more you know like
guys like Robert Patrick who came on and
Michael bean from Aliens and tombs these
guys let go and they [__] talk about
what they want to say Legends Legends
and JK Simmons and talking about his
brother's suicide and like I it's just
real [__] yeah and I appreciate it
thanks for coming out love you buddy
love you too man thank you
[Music]
there you have it I hope you enjoyed
that interview
um if you liked it please uh follow us
on our socials at inside youpod cast on
Instagram and Facebook Ryan and that
inside of you pod on the Twitter join
patreon to support the podcast if you
liked it write a review it helps the
podcast so much and uh Ryan you doing
all right hanging in there are you as
are you as are we all yeah I'm just
trying to hang in there uh it's just you
know sometimes things happen and you
just have to
it's it's part of the equation it's like
it's it's part of your life now so like
what do you do you just go okay uh
hopefully this this will get better this
will get better that's all you can hope
for yeah man things happen that's all
they ever do
yeah yeah I took a nice pot Taffy last
night and that helped and I watched um
some stuff I watched
some Ghost Hunters [__] some Ghost
Hunters but I mean that's kind of what
the reality series is gonna be it's not
we're not Ghost Hunters we're just two
guys who love horror and are goofy and
are gonna go see if stuff's really scary
what if you actually have like a ghost
experience like a
I'll ship my pants yeah if I have a
ghost experience
um everyone will know they'll know
because I'll I'll be so you'll see
animated and oh yeah I'll be emotional
about it I'm sure so it's called scared
it won't come out until next year but um
you know a lot of cool stuff going on
and um hoping the strike will end
so um people can start getting back to
work and all that
um things are slowly happening it looks
like a on that front slowly happening I
think things are starting to ameliorate
did you watch a spelling bee last night
no it's a word that I learned in word
power in high school and I use it it
means to become better
ameliorate ameliorate
I lost a spelling bee in fourth grade
once on the word Autumn because I was
saying
N I got ahead of myself and I forgot the
U really F you Ryan I know for missing
that I have not forgotten I I was in a
spelling bee too and first they do the
whole school and I got narrowed down to
the top ten but I wasn't I was a decent
speller but I wasn't a good student but
like any time there was competition or
something
I would I remember my teacher Mrs Meyer
she would teach us she taught us a lot
of things very few good teachers in my
life she was one of them but the
spelling of Encyclopedia she taught us
in song e and c y c l o p e d i a
she also taught us the linking verbs is
Mr was were B Bing bin has have had do
does did shall will should may my musk
can could
that's cool yeah and now she's in the
soap game
what do you mean Mrs Meyer oh my or so
yeah pretty good all right we love you
thanks for watching the podcast this
right now it's uh the patron the top
tier patrons who uh they get boxes from
me every couple of months and I sign
stuff and write little notes and you get
a bunch of cool stuff so join patreon
and if you want to be a top tier that's
great you're really helping the podcast
patreon.com inside you but let's go to
the top tiers Ryan I'm going to read
them out and maybe I'll do an impression
and you'll try to see if you can do it
if I can't I'll just read it
little Lisa Yukiko that was anything
like I said
Jill e Brian H Nico B Robert B Jason w
Sophie
Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal f
Janelle B Mac e l down Supremo 1009 more
99 more I'm gonna give a little will for
Brimley
diabetes
um what does he say he says uh have a
bowl of Quaker Oats Santiago Wham Chad W
lien p matius
Belinda n Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray H
Tabitha T
Tom and Talia M that City Angel Emery
and see him
Cody k
iff Nixon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
Joey M Eugene and Leah you got it at the
end I did I was trying to do a Hugh
Grant and it wasn't working because I
thought that's what you were doing yeah
uh but I I of course corrected you
corrected yourself I course corrected
Corey Jake B Angela F Mel s Christine s
r
Jen B Kevin e Stephanie K jorel Jamma J
Leanne J Lena Luna r ulana Mike F Stone
h
yla stay wild moonchild Brian L Kendall
L Cara C Jessica B
Kyle F Marisol P Kaylee J Brian a Ashley
F Marion Louisiana Romeo B Veronica Q
Frank page NT Nikki L April R Cassie B
Derek n jdw Michelle L combomb Ginger
Insomniac and Rachel D we love you all
thank you for supporting the podcast and
until next time I'm Michael Rosenbaum
from the Hollywood Hills in Hollywood
California ah Brian tales doing another
voice well yeah yeah we love you guys
thanks for uh putting up with us and
hopefully you enjoyed the podcast until
next time please be good to yourself
my dogs are barking
foreign